Oh print area and Megan are less than
two months away from saying I do but
they took a break from all the wedding
planning to enjoy a little fun and game
the details are in tonight for go report
print area and Megan Marco looked like
the perfect royal match today Megan
rocked a sporty laid-back look and black
bootcut jeans and heels the couple both
wore polo shirts to the UK team trials
for the Invictus games a competition for
wounded servicemen and women that Harry
found it a source tells ET that the
couple is expected to travel to
Australia for the Invictus games which
kick off there in October this is their
11th public event together and we have
exclusive details and how Megan is
training to be a royal with just 43 days
to go a source tells ET Markel has been
studying binders with information on the
Commonwealth and the War Eagle family
our source tells us quote she's a quick
learner and call this a kind of dress
rehearsal before Megan Supes character
leaves the show for good
she'll tie the knot later this month on
the show's season finale with TV fiance
Patrick J Adams Megan and I have been
you know so close from the beginning of
the show doesn't finally get to that
moment was really great
Yugi spoke to Adams and his wife Troian
Bellisario at an event benefiting the
anti-hunger charity this bar saves lives
now what will you get them as a royal
couple if you go to the wedding or not
we send like a toaster they were trying
to choose between like a blender or a
bread maker you know that's something
classy look at you I got Vitamix
they don't have one of those fancy yeah
she's gonna need a Vitamix yeah she's in
to help yeah is there going to be a
royal wedding party at your house and
that's a miracle is the answer Prince
Harry is very cute actress Kristen Bell
the charities co-founder is ready to
celebrate the new royal couple I thought
you might be having like a fascinator
party you seem like now that you mention
it I feel like I like any excuse for a
party
that's what I say
[Music]